Color cameras are functionally equivalent
to the system of cones that we have in the
retinas of our eye.
Incoming light from the scene is focused by
a lens onto an artificial retina.
This artificial retina comprises an array
of silicone photo sensors.
These are solid state circuits that measure
the amount of incoming light.
They are actually sensitive to quite a broad
spectrum of light.
So to make them color sensitive we print on
top of these silicone sensors individual color
filters where we print patterns of red, green
and blue filters.
This gives the individual silicone photo sensor
then the ability to measure the amount of
incoming red, green or blue light at that
particular point on the artificial retina.
Most color cameras use an array of color filters
that looks something like this.
This pattern of color filters is frequently
referred to as a Bayer filter array, and is
named after Bryce Bayer who invented this
idea way back in 1976.
The fundamental element in the Bayer filter
is a two by two grid and it contains two green
filters one red filter and one blue filter.
For the purpose of example, imagine that each
of the underlying photo sensors is returning
these particular values and these are unsigned
eight bit integer numbers which vary between
0 and 255.
And further, let’s consider we want to measure
the amount of red, green and blue at this
particular point on the artificial retina.
Well the answer for red is really pretty clear,
the amount of red at this point is 75, it
is what is being returned by the photo sensor
after the light has passed through the overlying
red filter.
But let’s say now that I want to know the
amount of green light at this particular location
and that is problematic because this particular
sensor has got a red filter on it there is
no way that I can measure the amount of green
light there because there is a red filter
not a green filter.
Now what we do is simply average the green
value of all of the neighbours and we say
that this is a good approximation to the amount
of green light at the pixel that is circled.
Similarly, if you want to measure the amount
of blue light at this particular pixel we
take the average of the neighbouring blue
pixels.
So for every pixel in this array we can measure
directly one color and we can estimate two
other colors from its neighbours.
If our sensor is an NxM pixel array, then
we can estimate the red, green and blue values
of every pixel.
That means than we have a total of 3xNxM values
returned from this artificial retina.
But in reality there are only NxM actual measurements
being made.
There are only that many individual photo
sensors.
The rest of the values have been estimated.
So an alternative approach is just to store
the values directly measured by the photo
sensors—the NxM value—and then also take
note of the properties of the color filters
that are associated with the different pixels
and this is an alternative way of representing
the image and this is referred to as a raw
image file format.
It is different to a normal red, green and
blue image.
We need to do some post processing; we need
to apply the characteristics of the filters
in the camera to the data that is stored within
the file.